よっしゃー
うぉいアーーッ♂
あ、待ってもうもう無理かも
もう無理かも
wwちょっと待って
もう無理もう無理
これでいいや
はい！
あーーーあーー
今　ここ　トミックさんの家なんですけども
彼は今
なぜかというと
猫の写真を撮ってこようというアホらしい企画に出ています
トミックさんと僕が猫の写真を撮ろうという
ちょっと意味不明な企画をやっているという定で
僕とトミックさんホントは外に出てるんですけども
僕だけこっそり帰ってきて
今、この撮影をしています
ドッキリをしようと思います
名付けて
自分の顔が印刷されたボールが
トイレにめちゃくちゃ大量に入っているドッキリでございます　よっ！
というわけで
こちらトミックボールでございます
1箱250個入ってるので
1000,2000,3000,4000
¡¡¡¡¡¡4000!!!!!!
こちらに今110kg以上のトミックさんの顔が書かれたボールがありますww
開けてみましょう
うわはっはっｈぁつwwwwww
はいトミックボールこんな感じでございます
はいというわけでこんな感じのトミックさんの顔が描かれたボールが
今こちらに4000個あるので
トミックさんの部屋の一つを
このボールでいっぱいにしたいんすよ僕は。
僕はトミックさんにねもっとこう自分を愛する気持ちをつちかってほしいので
今から　トミックさんが多分猫の写真撮ってると思うんすよ今
トミトミ：オス♂ですね多分
トミックさんが猫の写真を撮ってる間に頑張って
UUUMのスタッフの方も呼んであるので
皆さんで頑張ってトミックさんのトイレの部屋を
このトミックさんの顔のプリントが描かれたボールでいっぱいにして
彼に
もっと自分を愛する力を付けてもらいたいと思います
ではいこう！
では入れていきます
トミトミ：13ニャー　14ニャー
二つ合わせて
アァーーン
*無慈悲なカット*
やばいもうここの段ボールが限界まで迫ってきました
ちょっと盛るくらいでもうちょっといけそうです
はい、これぐらいでございます
*拍手*
うわーーやばいな
せーのっ
*笑*
あの余談を許さない状況です
もう扉が限界まで圧迫されてるんで
ちょっとでも揺らしたりするとトミックさんが全員出てきてしまいます
なので今押さえてもらいながらトミックさんの帰りを待ちます
ではトミックさんの帰りを待ちましょう
はじめ：撮りました？猫
トミトミ：20匹¿¿
トミトミ：いや23匹ィ??
トミトミ：そんくらいは余裕のよっちゃんだな
はじめ：撮りました撮りました
トミトミ：まあ一回お披露目会しましょうや
スタッフ：そうですね、じゃあ準備するので
ではトイレに来たので
トミックさんを呼びます
トミックさーーん？
トイレ開かないんですけど
まじで開かないんですけど
トイレ開かないっす
なんかめっちゃ固い
はじめ：なんか挟まってるのかな
トミトミ：挟まってね？
はじめ：めっちゃ固いんですよでも
うわ！！うわあああ
トミトミ：おいお前まじでこれ
トミトミ：まじでお前さ
でもこんなに
おーーーーーいーーー
こんな幸せなことないですよでも
トミトミ：片づけろよwwお前これ
トミックさん飛び込みたくないんですか？この